So just to drive the point home
a little bit I just want to write down,
sort of summarize what it is that
we've talked about so far and
how it all kind of comes together.
And I think it's actually going to
push it back to the very first slide.
So, we've done MDPs
we talk about SMDP's.
We talked a little about what
options actually do for you,
And we talked a little bit
about state abstraction before.
This all brings us to
a bunch of neat little facts.
The first one is that because we
are doing this SNDP type thing,
because we are doing options.
We get to inherit all of the optimality
guarantees up to a point
of what we had before in regular
MDPs with regular actions.
So in particular we get all
the convergence proofs,
we get all the stability proofs.
In other words,
everything is all nice, and well, and
good in SMDP land as it was in MDP land.
There's a slight caveat to that
which is worth mentioning, and
it's really what you
brought up over the quiz.
Which is well if we don't pay attention
all these things, and we live around in
the options space are we actually
going to be able to really be optimal?
We really going to build
to solve the problem?
Do I need to know all of these things?
And the answer is, well if you've got
the right sort of options in the right
side of world, right kind of world,
then in fact, everything's good.
But you cannot guarantee that if
all you do is reason over options,
that you will in fact end
up with an optimal policy.
We have another notion called
hierarchical optimality.
And that's the notion that given
the set of options that you have,
you can in fact converge to an optimal
policy with respect to those options.
And I think that makes sense.
And of course whether you are allow
those options to pay attention
to all of the state space,
also affects whether you're going to get
the true optimality that you would have.
Or only a sort of optimality with
respect to the particular set of
options, and the states,
the state features that you happen to be
paying attention But I actually don't
think this is a big deal right because I
think this is true for
the problem in general.
So I've got an MDP and
I have a bunch of states.
I made up the states anyway
as we've talked about
before we talk about the palm and
MDPs and PSRs.
It's not clear these dates actually
exist in some very real sense.
I came up with the state features
I described the way the world was
supposed to be.
There're clearly some ways of describing
the state of Pac-Man that make learning
easier and some that make it harder,
some that allow us to be truly optimal,
and some that don't.
Like if I had came up with
state features that only track
the closest dots to me
I may not be optimal.
But on the other hand it
might be easier to learn and
these are tradeoffs that
we make all the time.
So, in some sense we're always dealing
with a limited notion of optimality.
Which we define with respect to
the set of actions we decide
that we're going to consider
in the set of state features
that we're going to pay any
attention to at any given time.